[Musik]
denkt mal darüber nach wenn wir jemanden
von euch fragen würden warum Nordkorea
so arm ist bin ich mir ziemlich sicher
dass die Antwort in den meisten Fällen
ganz klar lauten würde das liegt doch
vollkommen auf der handmark weil es eben
ein kommunistisches Land ist allerdings
meine Lieben Zuschauer hat genau diese
Antwort einen gewaltigen Haken denn
warum ist Nordkorea denn eigentlich so
viel ärmer als z.B China oder sogar Kuba
warum ist es ein viel ärmeres und
rückständigeres Land als die Sowjetunion
oder Titus Jugoslawien es jemals waren
und nicht nur das es mag euch nämlich
überraschen aber nordkorea war nicht
immer eine so elendes Land und es
herrschte auch nicht immer die extreme
Armut unter der es heute leidet außerdem
gab es eine Zeit in der Nordkorea als
eine Art Modell für den Sozialismus in
der gesamten sozialistischen Welt
angesehen wurde und Südkorea dagegen als
armer und korrupter Schandfleck in der
kapitalistischen Welt nordkorea hat
damals sogar haltet euch fest
Lebensmittel an Südkorea gespendet etwas
was heutzutage völlig verrückt klingt 30
September 1984 Nordkorea liefert
fluthilfsgüter an Südkorea 370 offene
Lastwagen lieferten tonnenweise
reismikamente und Kleidung ab die der
Norden als Hilfsgüter für die Opfer der
jüngsten Überschwemmungen im Süden
bereitgestellt hatte damals in den
frühen 1980er Jahren lag die
nordkoreanische Getreideproduktion bei
über 10 Millionen Tonnen pro Jahr heute
ist sie weniger als halb so hoch in der
Tat hat Nordkorea ein solches debarkel
erlitten dass es heute nicht einmal mehr
die überzeugtesten Anhänger des
Kommunismus wagen würden sich mit der
wirtschaftlichen oder sozialen
Entwicklung dieses Landes zu brüsten es
sei den natürlich sie sind Fans des
Absurden aber Moment mal warum behaupten
wir dann dass Nordkorea einst ein
Musterland für die Anhänger
sozialistischer Revolutionen war was ist
seitdem passiert dass dieses Land zu
einem abstoßenden Gegenbeispiel wurde
was sind die Hauptgründe für die große
und weit verbreitete extreme Armut dort
heute werden wir all diese Fragen
natürlich beantworten und zwar gleich
nach der kurzen Botschaft des Sponsors
das heutige Video mglich gemacht hat AG1
AG1 ist ein Nahrungsergänzungsmittel das
nicht nur von namhaften
Naturwissenschaftlern empfohlen wird
nein auch mir hilft es fit zu bleiben
was ich damit meine nun sicher könnt ihr
euch vorstellen dass dieser Job hier
nicht durchzuhalten wäre wenn man sich
nicht ordentlich in Form hält gerade in
diesen dunklen Wintertagen wenn die
Sonne schon früh untergeht und viele von
uns mit Müdigkeit kämpfen ist ist
entscheidend Wege zu finden um Energie
geladen zu bleiben AG1 das aus
jahrzehntelanger Forschung entstanden
und bereit 52 mal weiterentwickelt und
optimiert wurde hilft mir während des
ganzen Arbeitstages im Flow zu bleiben
und meinen mentalen Fokus auf das zu
konzentrieren was wirklich zählt um mein
Energiestoffwechsel in Schwung zu halten
unterstützen mich folgende Bestandteile
meiner allmorgentlichen Portion AG1
Kupfer Biotin pantetonsäure tiamin und
die Vitamine B2 B12 und C das ist nicht
einfach so daher gesagt sagt sondern
eine evidenzbasierte Tatsache ihr glaubt
mir nicht dann überzeugt euch vielleicht
ja dass zahlreiche international
anerkannte Naturwissenschaftler die sich
ihr ganzes professionelles Leben mit
diesem Thema beschäftigen AG1 empfehlen
unter anderem so namhafte Fachleute wie
z.B Professor Dr andre D juberman
Neurowissenschaftler und Professor für
Neurobiologie an der Stanford School of
Medicine und Professor Dr David Andrew
sincl Biologe und Professor für Genetik
der sich auf die Erforschung von
Alterungsprozessen spezialisiert hat
okay klar ist ein Nahrungs
Ergänzungsmittel ersetzt keine
ausgewogene Ernährung deswegen heißt es
ja nur Ergänzungsmittel aber mal Hand
aufs Herz wer schafft es denn heutzutage
noch wirklich sich durchgängig
ausgewogen zu ernähren odne dass dafür
viel Zeit drauf geht und AG1 ist vor
allem nicht nur für meinen individuellen
Anwendungsbereich geeignet s bietet noch
viele weitere gesundheitliche Vorteile
über die ihr mehr erfahren könnt wenn
ihr auf den Link in der Beschreibung
klickt dort erfahrt ihr auch weitere
Details darüber welche Inhaltsstoffe
genau welchen Nutzen bringen und wie sie
optimal aufeinander abgestimmt sind um
Synergieeffekte und eine hohe bi verfüg
übarkeit zu erzielen fakt ist H1 ist
ketofreundlich und die wertvollen
Mikronährstoffe werden aus echten
natürlichen veganen Nahrungsmitteln wie
Erbsen oder Soja gewonnen ohne
künstliche Zusatzstoffe außerdem schmckt
es auch noch gut mir
zumindest natürlich darf man es wie
alles nicht überdosieren sollte auf
Allergene achten und vor allem nicht
einnehmen wenn man schwanger ist oder
stillt ich empfehle euch auf jeden Fall
mal eine Ernährungsberatung zu machen um
festzustellen was genau ihr braucht um
euch besser zu fühlen und gesünder zu
leben mir persönlich hilft die oben
genannte Kombination aus AG1 am besten
denn es deckt meiner Ansicht nach die
meisten Fälle zufriedenstellend ab und
passend dazu bietet H1 unseren
Zuschauern sogar ein besonderes Angebot
wenn du auf den Link in der
Videobeschreibung klickst erhältst du
bei Abschluss eines monatlichen Abos
einen kostenlosen Jahresvorrat an
Vitamin D3 und K2 und fünf praktische H1
travel Packs für unterwegs gratis dazu
neukunden erhalten außerdem das H1
welcome Kit inklusive einer schicken
Aufbewahrungsdose und einem praktischen
Shaker das ganze ist ein Abo ohne
laufzeitbendung du kannst es also
jederzeit nachbieben anpassen pausieren
oder einfach kündigen also worauf
wchtest Du noch probier on doch einfach
mal ganz unverbindlich aus unterstütze
auch deine Ernährung auf einfache und
gesunde
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Weise bevor wir anfangen müssen wir uns
klar machen dass der Kommunismus nicht
der einzige Grund für die extreme Armut
im heutigen nordkorea ist denn um die
wahren Gründe zu verstehen müssen wir
einen tieferen Blick in die
Vergangenheit werfen genauer gesagt in
jene dunkle Zeit des 20 Jahrhunderts als
die Welt schon einmal in zwei große
Blöcke geteilt war den kapitalistischen
und den kommunistischen Block und passt
gut auf denn in diesem Video werden wir
euch nicht erzählen dass Nordkorea bis
Mitte der 70er Jahre reicher war als
Südkorea denn das habt ihr bestimmt
schon öfter gehört sogar auf diesem
Kanal wovon ihr allerdings vielleicht
noch nicht so viel gehört habt ist die
Tatsache dass Nordkorea bis etwa
1993 und das ist noch gar nicht so lange
her China beim prokopf BEP übertroffen
hat und stark vereinfacht kann man das
so interpretieren dass es tatsächlich
eine reicheres Land war lasst mich das
noch mal wiederholen wir sprechen über
das Jahr
1993 das ist wirklich noch nicht so
lange her vor allem wenn wir an den
Abgrund denken der diese beiden Länder
heute trennt denn wir können im Grunde
sagen dass dieses Isolier Land vom
Musterschüler mit Bestnoten im
kommunistischen Orbit zu einem Land
wurde das nicht einmal einen einzigen
Test bestehen
[Musik]
kann einer der Aspekte über den nicht so
oft gesprochen wird ist dass es auch
innerhalb des kommunistischen Blocks
große Unterschiede zwischen den Ländern
in Bezug auf Wohlstand und Entwicklung
gab und ja Nordkorea gehörte zu den
wohlhabenden und fortschrittlichen
kommunismusschüler der damaligen Zeit
innerhalb der Realität des
kommunistischen Blocks zumindest wir
sprechen über die 1960er und vor allem
die 1970er Jahre mehr noch in den 80er
Jahren waren die Nordkorea etwas reicher
als heute trotzdem kann man nicht sagen
dass das Land heute kommunistischer sei
als damals in den 80ern es muss also
eine andere Erklärung geben was um alles
in der Welt ist also passiert was könnte
die extreme Armut erklären die Nordkorea
seit Jahrzehnten plagt nun um den
Absturz dieses Landes zu verstehen ist
es meiner Meinung nach wichtig zuerst zu
begreifen warum es überhaupt aufsteigen
konnte denn ja die Wahrheit ist dass
Nordkorea relativ glückliche Zeiten
hatte und das was damals getan wurde und
wie es getan wurde hat zu einem großen
Teil zu dem Ergebnis geführt dass wir
heute kennen also meine Lieben Zuschauer
macht euch bereit überrascht zu
werden das sozialistische
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Musterland der koreerkrieg der die
beiden neuegründeten schwesterstaaten
Nord und Südkorea zwischen 1950 und 53
gegeneinander ausspielte zerstörte fast
alles und stürzte die beiden Staaten in
eine massive wirtschaftliche und
humanitäre Krise damals wurde das
wirtschaftliche Abschneiden des einen
oder anderen Landes nach dem Krieg in
gewisser Weise als Beweis dafür gesehen
welches der beiden Systeme das
kapitalistische oder das kommunistische
besser war heute mag das unerhört
erscheinen aber damals schien alles
offen und zwar auch und vor allem unter
vielen intellektuellen und Akademikern
in der westlichen Welt selbst in den USA
aus diesem Grund nahmen die beiden
Großmächte der damaligen Zeit die Hilfe
für ihren jeweiligen koreanischen
Verbündeten in der Nachkriegszeit
verdammt ernst die USA und andere
westliche Verbündete halfen Südkorea mit
einem Geldregen und zinsgünstigen oder
sogar zinslosen Darlehen und in der
gleichen Zeit überschwemmten auch die
Sowjetunion und China Nordkorea mit Geld
Nord und Südkorea sollten die
Aushängeschilder des jeweiligen Systems
werden zwischen 1950 und 1970 stellten
China und die Sowjetunion jeweils rund 2
Milliarden Dollar zur Verfügung hinzu
kommt eine enorme Menge an Ressourcen
die für den Wiederaufbau des Landes und
auch für die nordkoreanische
Industrialisierung von großer Bedeutung
[Musik]
waren es ging darum die gesteckten Ziele
um jeden Preis zu erreichen um die
Industrialisierung mit voller Kraft
voranzutreiben und den Wettlauf mit dem
südlichen Nachbaren zu gewinnen bediente
sich der nordkoreanische Staat mehrerer
Formeln andererseits aber die Schaffung
einer sozialen Bewegung die alle seine
Ziele unterstützt und dieser Plan war
zunächst relativ erfolgreich der
fünjahresplan von 1957 bis 60 löste die
größten nachkriegsprobleme in den
Bereichen Ernährung und Wohnungsbau und
machte das Land bereit für die
Massenproduktion und die
massenindustrialisierung nun ja
zumindest dachte man
das zwischen 1935 als der Krieg endete
und 58 betrug die durchschnittliche
industrielle Wachstumsrate Nordkorea
sagenhaftte
43% pro Jahr aber Vorsicht denn die
Wirtschaft auf der Stra stße entwickelte
sich nicht in demselben Tempo um das zu
ändern wurde 1958 die sogenannte
scholima Bewegung gegründet eine Version
der sowjetischen stachanof Bewegung die
als Nordkoreas Konkurrenz zu Maos großen
Sprung nach vorn interpretiert wurde im
Gegensatz zum großen Sprung nach vorne
in China gibt es allerdings einen
Konsens darüber dass die scholima
Bewegung einen gewissen Erfolg hatte
Ziel des Plans war es vor allem die
Produktivität der Arbeiter zu steigern
um dies zu erreichen wurden kaum
materielle Entlohnungen eingeführt aber
es wurden Produktionsziele festgelegt
die sogar eine Verdopplung der
Produktion im Vergleich zum Vorjahr
vorsahen und die besten Arbeiter wurden
dann von der Propaganda als
übermenschlich gut und als wahre Helden
des Volkes
dargestellt und die Wahrheit ist dass
dieser Plan teilweise funktioniert hat
die industrielle und landwirtschaftliche
Produktion hat sich zwar nicht in einem
Jahr verdoppelt aber sch scholema hatte
eine gewisse
Wirkung so stiegt die
Industrieproduktion in insbesondere die
Stahlproduktion 1959 um 53% gegenüber
dem Vorjahr die Arbeiter verlängerten
ihre Arbeitszeit auf 10 oder gar 12
Stunden pro Tag und begannen an
Wochenenden und Feiertagen zu arbeiten
all das um die Ziele zu erreichen die im
Rahmen eines enormen patriotischen
Eifers gesetzt wurden und tatsache ist
dass es dem Land zwischen den 1960er und
70er Jahren ziemlich gut ging vor allem
wenn man bedenkt von wo aus es gestartet
war in den 70er Jahren verzeichnet es
jährliche BIP Wachstumsraten von mehr
als 10 % in manchen Jahren sogar fast
25%. zu dieser Zeit entwickelte sich die
landwirtschaftliche Produktion auf
rasante Weise verdreifachte sich
innerhalb eines Jahrzehnts und
währenddessen strömten billiges Öl aus
der Sowjetunion und industrielle
Technologie aus der DDR und anderen
osteuropäischen Ländern nach Nordkorea
all dies ermöglichte die Entwicklung
einer weitaus fortschrittlicheren
Industrie als es sie damals in Südkorea
oder in China gab tatsächlich stieg das
nominale prokov BEP zwischen den frühen
70er Jahren und 1985 von 384 auf 836 30
USDollar das war immer noch ein sehr
niedriges Niveau aber um euch eine
Vorstellung davon zu geben China
schaffte es erst 10 Jahre später im Jahr
1955 zum ersten Mal die Marke von 600$
pro Kopf zu überstreiten außerdem
erlebte pyionyang ein schnelles
städtisches Wachstum neue Industrien
siedelt sich rund um die Hauptstadt an
sie war sozusagen zu einer
sozialistischen Modellstadt geworden mit
sehr breiten und sauberen Alleen
gepflegten gerkten Springbrunnen
Straßenbahnen und U-Bahnen alles schien
wie am Schnürchen zu laufen in der
kommunistischen Welt gab es damals nur
wenige solche Fälle wenn überhaupt und
für viele kam das was in Nordkorea
geschah einem Wunder
[Musik]
gleich das rasante Wachstum in dieser
Zeit ging mit einem Anstieg der
Lebenserwartung auf 70 Jahre und einem
Rückgang der Kindersterblichkeit von
etwa 120 Kindern pro 1000 Geburten auf
etwa 30 einher und in den 80er Jahren
wurde pyionyang schließlich zu eine der
modehauptstädte Asiens mit großem
Einfluss auf China und andere Länder des
damaligen sozialistischen Orbits aber
nicht nur das der andere Eckpfeiler des
nordkoreanischen Wachstums in den 60er
und 70er Jahren war neben der
Stahlindustrie auch der Bergbau
Mineralien wie Magnesit das z.B in der
stallindustrie oder im Bauwesen
verwendet wird Zink wolfrah und Eisen
sie alle wurden nicht nur Nordkoreas
eigen Industrie verwendet sondern auch
in großen Mengen im Tausch gegen der
Wiesen Öl und Technologie
exportiert wenn es zu dieser Zeit ein
kommunistisches Land gab das bereit war
durchzustarten dann war es das Land auf
das alle Augen richtet
waren all dies verhalf Nordkorea
natürlich zu einer gewissen
internationalen Bedeutung in der
sozialistischen Welt ein Einfluss den
pyyang ausnutzte und zudem hoffte ihn
über die andere Seite des Eisernen
Vorhangs hinaus auszuweiten und wie
wollten sie das anstellen nun ihr müsst
verstehen dass Nordkorea in den 70er und
80er Jahren eine eigene Version der
Globalisierung entwickeln wollte ein
Modell dass das Land zu einer Art Brücke
zwischen den Ländern des kommunistischen
blocks und den blockfien Ländern machen
sollte und so begann Nordkorea die
Beziehungen zu afrikanischen Ländern wie
Algerien aber auch zu anderen Ländern im
Nahen Osten und in Südostasien zu
stärken und den Handel zu fördern sie
nahmen sogar Beziehungen zu einigen
lateinamerikanischen Ländern auf
unterstützten revolutionäre oder
antikoloniale Bewegungen in Afrika und
ja all das mag denjenigen unter euch die
etwas über Nordkorea verstehen
widersprüchlich erscheinen schließlich
basiert die chuter Ideologie die
einheimische nordkoreanische Version des
Sozialismus auf autarchie und ja ihr
habt aber die Realität ist etwas
[Applaus]
komplexer wie wir gesehen haben waren
Nordkorea kein besonders erfolgreiches
Land aber es war mehr oder weniger ein
guter Ort zum Leben natürlich im
kommunistischen Kontext und es war
sicherlich Welten entfernt von der
heutigen Situation es gab eine gewisse
Perspektive auf Wohlstand also wie und
warum ist es dann zu der heutigen
traurigen Situation gekommen wie konnte
es passieren dass ein nach
sozialistischen Maßstäben recht
wohlhabendes Land Ende der 90er Jahre
eine der schlimmsten Hungersnöte der
Menschheitsgeschichte erlebte welche
entscheidenden Fehler hat die Führung
des Landes begannen um das Land in ein
so verarmtes und rückständiges Land zu
verwandeln nun keine Angst heute
erzählen wir euch alles darüber wenn die
Geschichte Nordkoreas ein Film wäre wäre
dies genau der Moment in dem die
Spannung und Dramatik des Soundtracks
umschlägt und wir alle ahnen schon dass
etwas verdammt schlimmes passieren
wird die Gründe des
Scheiterns die politische Ideologie
Nordkoreas ist geprägt von einer Doktrin
ihrer eigenen Version des Kommunismus
die von Diktator Kim irsan eingeführt
wurde die Rede ist von juche in der
Praxis bedeutet juutche die Einführung
von autarchie als Mittel zur
Verteidigung der Souveränität des Landes
und der Revolution wir sprechen von
einem System das eine Art Mischung aus
ich mach selbst und ich brauche keine
Hilfe ist gewürzt mit einer Menge
kommunistischer Theorie genau das ist
juche eine Philosophie die in der
Theorie toll klingt aber in der Praxis
viel schwieriger umzusetzen ist als ein
Ikea Möbelstück ohne Anleitung
zusammenzubauen aber wartet einen Moment
denn wie wir euch bereits gesagt haben
hat Nordkorea trotzdem viel mit anderen
Ländern des sozialistischen Blocks
Handel getrieben mit diesen Ländern
wurden nicht nur viele Waren importiert
und exportiert nein in Nordkorea lie
sich auf viel Geld von anderen
kommunistischen Ländern sowie auch von
westlichen und sogar japanischen
Banken
vor allem in den 70er Jahren unterhielt
pionyang Geschäfte mit mehr als 100
Banken aus 17 Ländern mit diesem Geld
sollten die Ausweitung des Bergbaus im
Land der Bau und die Lebensmittelimporte
finanziert werden außerdem wurde die
bergbauproduktion regelrecht gedobt um
den Preisverfall bei einigen der vom
Land exportierten Mineralien
auszugleichen der Sektor war zu ein Art
goldenen ganz für das Regime in
pyionyang geworden und die einzige
Möglichkeit genug Geld zu verdienen um
auch seine Importe weiterhin zu
finanzieren angesichts fallender
Weltmarktpreise für ruhstoffe bestand
darin die Produktion immer weiter in die
Höhe zu
treiben tja aber offensichtlich war das
eine sehr schlechte
Idee schon bald waren die Nordkoreaner
nicht mehr in der Lage die Kredite
zurückzuzahlen in den Jahren 1977 80 und
74 kam es dann zu Umschuldungen und
Nordkorea war schließlich nicht mehr in
der Lage seine Kredite überhaupt
zurückzuzahlen es geriet quasi in
permanent Verzug und das war der erste
Grund für den Anfang vom Ende des
nordkoreanischen Wunders 23 August 1987
Nordkorea erfährt von Kreditausfall der
Gesamtbetrag der geschuldeten
Kreditbeträge und Zinsen beläuft sich
auf etwa 770 Millionen Dollar von den
1,65 bis 2,75 Milliarden Dollar die
Nordkorea der nichtkommunistischen Welt
vermutlich schuldet der Rest wird
hauptsächlich von japanischen Banken
gehalten das Kapital und die Zinsen die
bei den Finanzinstituten aufgelaufen
sind belaufen sich jetzt auf 3,6
Milliarden USDollar und dabei wurde ein
großer Schuldenerlass gegenüber Russland
in Höhe von 90% der Schulden bei diesem
ehemaligen kommunistischen Partner
berücksichtigt insgesamt belaufen sich
die auslandchulden des Landes laut dem
international journal of Korean
unification studies auf zwischen 6 und
15 Milliarden
USDollar und tatsache ist dass die
Zahlungsausfälle dermaßen schwerwegend
waren dass es zu solchen dantesken
Situation wie dieser kam 14 November
2023 Nordkoreas nie bezahlte Volvos
fahren nach fast 50 Jahren immer noch
das schwedische Amt für
Exportkreditgarantien ekn schät die
ausstehenden Schulden für die 1000
volvoofahrzeuge die Nordkorea vor fast
50 Jahren bestellt hat auf 2,9
Milliarden Schwedische Kronen das sind
267 Millionen US-Dollar der
ursprüngliche Kaufvertrag belief sich
auf 600 Millionen Kronen und ich weiß
was er jetzt denkt aber Mark kein Land
verhungert und wird für 30 Jahre auf
unbestimmte Zeit eingefroren nur weil es
Schulden hat da muss es doch noch etwas
anderes geben und ja ihr habt wieder
recht zu behaupten dass Nordkorea einzig
und allein wegen seiner unbezahlten
Schulden in der Zeit feststeckt wäre so
als würde man sagen dass eine Party
ruiniert ist nur weil das Eis
ausgegangen ist es ist vollkommen klar
dass es mehr Faktoren geben muss ja und
die Wahrheit ist dass es wirklich noch
viel mehr davon gibt abgesehen davon
dass sie nicht in der Lage waren ihrre
produktionsmodelle an die globalen
Veränderungen anzupassen wurden auf dem
Weg dorthin weitere fatale Fehler
begangen Fehler die viel mehr mit der
fehlenden marktperspektive der mangelen
Überwachung und Kontrolle durch die
Machthaber und natürlich der Korruption
zu tun
haben zwei Schlüsselelemente erklären
warum sich Nordkorea heute in einem
derart miserablen Zustand befindet
erstens gab es in den 80er Jahren in
Nordkorea anders als im Rest der
kommunistischen Welt keine wesentlichen
Reformen des wirtschaftlichen und
politischen Systems etwas das z.B in
China oder Vietnam passiert ist dadurch
blieb die nordkoreanische Wirtschaft von
der Globalisierung ausgeschlossen und
ohne Investitionen dies bedeutete
wiederum dass ihr ihre
wettbewbsfähigkeit allmählich abnahm die
neuen chinesischen Fabriken waren viel
produktiver unter anderem dank der
Beziehungen zum Westen und so begann
nordkoreanische Unternehmen und ganze
Industrien entweder zu verschwinden oder
so veraltet zu sein dass sie nicht mehr
konkurrenzfähig waren infolgedessen
gingen ihre Exporte stark zurück während
die chinesischen und südkoreanischen
Nachbaren ihre Türen weit öffneten und
ausländische Investitionen Technologien
erhielten wurde Nordkorea von diesem
Prozess völlig ausgeschlossen mit
anderen Worten während China und
Südkorea den Anschluss an die moderne
Welt fanden war Nordkorea wie der Typ
der nicht aufhören will Schlaghosen zu
tragen und Videokassetten zu gucken der
zweite und vielleicht noch wichtigste
Grund ist dass Nordkorea seit den 70er
Jahren und verstärkt in den 80er Jahren
ein riesiges militärisches
Expansionsprogramm startete dieses
Programm zielte darauf ab die
vollständige militärische Unabhängigkeit
Nordkoreas zu erreichen damit es im
Kriegsfall weder von den Sowjets noch
von den Chinesen abhängig wäre und diese
Entscheidung hatte zwei schwerwiegende
Auswirkungen zum einen wurden enorme
Ressourcen von der zivilen Wirtschaft
zum Militär umgeleitet und zum anderen
wurde die Entwicklung neuer
Infrastrukturen die die produktive
Wirtschaft hätten stärken können
vernachlässigt so kam es nach und nach
zu einem Verfall des Straßennetzes der
Hefen und der Wasserinfrastruktur was
Nordkorea äußerst anfällig für Dürren
und Überschwemmungen machte und das war
der Nährboden für all das was später kam
der extrem beschwerliche Weg über den
wir allerdings etwas später sprechen
werden tatsache ist dass die
Militarisierung des Landes eine
besorgniserregende Wendung zu nehmen
begann 1993 als der kommunistische Block
bereits zusammengebrochen war kündigte
Nordkorea seine Absicht an aus dem
atomwaffenperrvertrag auszutreten und
das obwohl das Land den Vertrag nur 8
Jahre zuvor ratifiziert hatte aber
wartet 1994 sagte es seinen Rückzug
zunächst ab aber 2003 zog es sich dann
doch schließlich vollkommen aus dem
Abkommen zurück 10 Juni 2003 Nordkorea
zieht sich aus atomabkommen zurück pyang
erklärte es reaktiviere die Anlagen in
jongbon als Vergeltung für die
Entscheidung washington die Öllieferung
auszusetzen nachdem der Norden die
Existenz des anderen geheimen
Atomprogramms aufgedeckt hatte meine
Lieben visualpolitik Zuschauer das
Regime in pyyang wollte ganz einfach
Massenvernichtungswaffen um jeden Preis
und diese verhängnisvolle Entscheidung
war quasi das Todesurteil für seine
sowieso schon kränkelnde
Wirtschaft ihr müsst nämlich verstehen
dass das Land Ende der 90er Jahre und
einer großen hungersnodlit der je nach
Quelle zwischen einer halben und 2
Millionen Menschen zum Opfer fiel und
selbst in dieser Situation hörte die
Regierung nicht auf immer mehr Geld für
die Rüstung abzuzweigen es ging sogar
soweit die internationale Hilfe zu
behindern weil Nordkorea als
ausländischen Organisation nicht
erlaubte die Verteilung der Hilfe zu
überprüfen sagen wir einfach dass das
Regime die Ressourcen und Gelder die zur
Linderung der Hungersnot ankamen um
jeden Preis selbst verwalten wollte und
dies interpretierten viele natürlich als
ein Versuch einen Teil der Hilfe für
andere Ziele umzuleiten bei denen es
nicht gerade darum ging Leben zu retten
das Schlimmste jedoch sollte noch kommen
dre Jahre später im Jahr 2006 führte
Nordkorea seinen ersten Atomtest durch
der mit dem ersten von der UNO
beschlossenen Paket von
Wirtschaftssanktionen gegen das Land
sowie mit unilateralen Sanktionen mehrer
Länder einherging es mag viele von euch
überraschenend aber bis 2006 also bis
vor nicht allzu langer Zeit war
Nordkorea wirtschaftlich durchaus in der
Lage fast uneingeschränkt zu importieren
und zu exportieren was es wollte seinem
ersten Atomwaffentest hat sich das
allerdings komplett geändert Nordkorea
wurde zum pari ja und durch immer mehr
Resolutionen des un Sicherheitsrats mit
Sanktionen belegt der Knackpunkt sind
aber nicht so sehr die Sanktionen sonder
die Entscheidung des Regimes sein Volk
zu opfern indem es mitten in einer
Hungersnot ein groß angelegtes nukleares
Entwicklungsprogramm startet und die
internationalen Reaktion darauf völlig
ignoriert aber wisst ihr was aus
politischer Sicht mag diese Strategie
für die Machthaber durchaus sinnvoll
gewesen sein der beste Beweis dafür ist
dass 20 Jahre später im Jahr 2024 das
Regime immer noch steht trotzdem hätte
die Idee aus Sicht der eigenen
Bevölkerung und Wirtschaft nicht
schlechter sein
können und Vladimir Putin sollte sich
wirklich zweimal überlegen ob er
wirklich denselben Weg gehen möchte nach
der großen Hungersnot die zum Teil auf
den Zusammenbruch des kommunistischen
Blocks und Nordkorea sinkende
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit zurückzuführen ist
hat sich das Land nie wieder erholt nach
dem brutalen Rückgang in den 90er Jahren
liegt das prokopf BEP immer noch auf
demselben Niveau wie in den 1960er
Jahren wir reden hier also von sage und
schreibe sechs verlorenen jahrzehinten
so da habt ihr die Gründe warum
Nordkorea der einztige aufsteigende
sterern der Sozialismus zu seiner
größten Blamage geworden ist und die
Frage ist wird diese Situation ewig
andauern nun im Moment sind keine
Veränderungen in Sicht aber wie ihr
wisst ist die koreanische Halbinsel ein
Ort über den wir hier auf visualpolitik
viel sprechen also werden wir auch
Nordkorea im Auge behalten vergessst
daher bitte nicht Fall nicht schon
geschehen unseren Kanal zu abonnieren
unbedingt auch mit Glöckchen um kein
spannendes video mehr zu verpassen wie
immer sind wir auch auf eure Meinung zu
diesem Thema im Kommentarbereich schon
mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dies Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht auch was dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt uns bitte ein Like T mit
euren Freunden und diskutiert es auch
mit ihnen natürlich freuen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
uns h dieses Projekt weiter zuuführen
den Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung dem Video mach's gut und
bis
[Musik]
bald